es un documental polémico pero todavía
no escandaloso ni controversial para la
familia real sobre todo para una pareja
que está obsesionada con proteger su
vida privada pero le ha abierto la
intimidad las puertas de su casa al
gigante de las comunicaciones Netflix
por un acuerdo económico que se especula
alrededor de los 100 millones de libras
esterlinas pues vienen estas tres
primeras entregas Harry y Megan han
revelado que tuvieron que dejar con
mucho pesar ser miembros activos de la
familia real hace varios años porque el
tratamiento que estaba sufriendo Megan
como parte de la familia real
especialmente por su raza Harry ha dicho
que estaba en la necesidad de tomar las
decisiones que fueran necesarias para
proteger a su esposa y a su familia
porque no quería que se repitiera la
historia de su madre que fue perseguida
casi que la muerte por los paparazzis
recordemos ese accidente de tránsito de
en 1997 cuando la princesa Diana murió
en París hay casi que una obsesión del
príncipe Harvey por encontrar puntos en
común entre Diana su madre y Megan su
esposa pero quienes conocieron a la
princesa Diana han dicho hace pocas
horas que lo que sufrió Diana en la
persecución de la prensa británica no es
nada no fue nada con lo si se compara lo
que está viviendo Megan por supuesto Así
que se han justificado entregado sus
razones han dicho que esa es la parte de
su historia y que esa es la verdad no se
contempla hasta el momento un
pronunciamiento del Rey Carlos III o de
la familia real pero lo cierto es que
hasta ahora se conoce la primera etapa
de estos documentales la próxima semana
se resbalarán los finales y recordemos
que Megan ha dicho que ha sufrido
racismo dentro de la familia real y que
su salud mental estuvo tan afectada que
incluso tuvo pensamientos suicidas Así
que habrá que